the people of wolverhampton go to the
polls tomorrow voting in local elections
which help shape the fabric of our
democracy and as politicians fret over
their own majorities it's a different
type of margin market traders here are
worried about the cost of living squeeze
firmly on their minds every single
person that comes to the store
nine out of ten are always asking for a
little bit of discount because they're
struggling everybody's struggling i
realize they're struggling that's why i
try and keep the price as low as
possible johnson
is doing okay apart from this cost of
living if he doesn't get the interest
rate under control it's plain and simple
the way people are talking he'll be out
of office for the next election party
gate do you care that much nope don't
care about the parties i respect care
about people's cost of living if you
notice that with your customers are they
worried about the cost of living they do
come in and they mention about
electricity bills uh gas bills and
diesel and everything
nearly everything i sell is going up how
long have you had the business for going
20 years now 20 years has ever been like
this before now this is the first time
this is the first time some of the fish
are doubling like i used to pay let's
say a 10 pounder box you buy it now it's
nearly 20 pounder box
and that's causing a headache for the
prime minister too
on a visit to southampton airport today
to offer a helping hand
and reassure voters the conservatives
are still fit for the job too the best
future for the country is
get through the
the tough patch that we have now support
people in any way that we can but
remember this is uh
as we're now seeing a lot of employment
and people in high-wage high-skill jobs
that's a much better position to be in
than we were in the 1980s or 1990s but
back in wolverhampton for brian who's
voted conservative since the 80s the
issue of party's trust and boris johnson
has stuck would you vote for him again
no you wouldn't no not for him now no i
think it's time for him to go and
somebody else coming and
trying to
do better
people of course vote on neighbourhood
and national issues when it comes to
local elections but the conversations
i've been having here in wolverhampton
centre on the issue affecting families
up and down the country wherever you may
live the cost of living crisis and that
combined with the irritation people feel
over the partygate scandal could prove a
toxic combination for boris johnson at
the ballot box
this opponent sees an opportunity today
the labour leader in wakefield a key
target for his party we've got a
positive message and we have been
laser-like in our focus on the cost of
living crisis because wherever you go
people come up particularly to me and
say look i can't pay my bills here
a cost of living crisis that threatens
to sink this government tomorrow's
elections will be the first real ballot
box test beth rigby sky news
wolverhampton